all right we are now live for another
reading from my
2011
book
uh reason
it's always weird reading it backwards
on this reason fulfilled by revelation
the 1930s christian philosophy debates
in france and we are still
in the middle of the
introduction which i i wrote myself it's
not the translations of the text that i
did
and it's providing a sort of
comprehensive overview of not just
what's in the text but what was
going on at the time how these different
thinkers
were involved with each other what their
different positions were what their
motivations
were for this so today we are going to
read um two sub-sections the paradox and
the scandal
gabriel marcel which
is actually uh fairly short and then
we're going to read uh neo-scholastic
tomist opponents of christian
philosophy which includes pierre
mandonette fernan von schteinbergen
um
leo noel
and marillo penito
so without any further ado i see we've
got a few people here we'll
do the reading and then i will take any
questions or comments after
the reading should take me probably
not quite half an hour or so so here we
go the paradox and the scandal
gabriel marcel
marcel's main contributions during the
debates outlining a fourth catholic
position for christian philosophy
take place in a pair of book reviews his
1933 presentation to the associated
philosophy is also of interest but is
passed over here because it is
translated already in being and having
and does not mention christian
philosophy specifically
reviewing the spirit of medieval
philosophy he necessarily discusses
etienne gilson's position but also
ranges over the rationalist
neo-scholastic and blundellian positions
and sets out another position pushing
christian philosophy still further than
do his compatriots
he first draws out an implication of
brahieres and the neo-scholastics
insistence that christianity has had no
positive influence on philosophical
development namely that christianity is
at bottom unintelligible for there is no
thought worthy of that name that is not
contributing to transforming all the
other thoughts this would then mean that
quote for human reason taking this word
in its widest signification christianity
constitutes a sort of perfectly opaque
foreign body
christian faith faith and revealed data
cannot in any manner organize itself
together with the totality of human
experience insofar as human experience
itself elaborates and elucidates itself
if christian philosophy cannot exist a
stark trilemma necessarily arises either
the christian philosopher the christian
revelation is unassimilated
assimilatable by the rational mind
or it is a disguised form or product of
natural reason
and not a genuine supernatural
revelation
or christianity is demoted to the status
of a moral stance a form of life
catholic philosophers and theologians
ought not be able to accept any of these
alternatives
and so the challenge posed by christian
philosophy's opponents must be met the
fact that jill some produces numerous
specific studies of medieval christian
philosophy indicating how christianity
made determinate contributions to
development of philosophies bespeaks the
falsity of the
position
betraying that it projects a screen of
dogmatic assumptions onto the history of
claims to investigate marcel notes by
pronouncing itself in this way a priori
on what is possible or not legitimate or
not in philosophy one sets oneself
precisely outside of the very conditions
of a philosophical activity because he
points out what is specific to
philosophy is that it does not derive
from any other jurisdiction superior to
itself that would assign to it such and
such limits such in such a limited
sphere of application
marcel argues for a heuristic function
to intellectuals religious commitments
and involvements affirming that quote
the notion of christian philosophy is
only susceptible of taking on meaning
for a consciousness if not christian at
least impregnated by christianity
by that very fact but capable of
apprehending the development of
doctrines following perspectives not
absolutely coinciding with those of the
historian pure and simple
julson's being a historian of the first
rank and an authentic christian
both statuses qualify him for a project
impossible to abrahiere
marcel argues that the rigorous
philosophical study of the issue cannot
be entirely separated from its personal
context what is needed is communication
with the figures and tradition of
christian philosophy striving to quote
grasp it in its deepest interior and
this he intimates may lead into and draw
upon quote participation in the
characters specific to the highest
religious life even an incorporation of
christian philosophers and philosophy
into the providential nexus
marcel pushes several theses even
further than jill sohn
embracing the conception of christianity
is making fertile contributions to
reason developed by philosophy he
stresses that this occurs not only by
contact with dogma but even more
precisely by an experience for itself as
clarified as possible of the religious
and even sacramental life
more provocatively yet he centers the
issue and the reality of christian
philosophy on the incarnation quote a
certain datum a revealed datum whose
signification whose value is absolutely
transcendent to any experience
susceptible of being constituted on
purely human bases
this project this provides a criterion
there is a christian philosophy only
where this paradox this scandal is not
only admitted or even accepted but
embraced with a passionate and
unrestricted gratitude
corresponding to this are temptations to
attenuate this scandal to mask the
paradox to reabsorb the revealed datum
into a dialectic of pure reason or mind
to render christian philosophies depth
and specific difference palatable to
non-christian philosophical perspectives
the result being that it ceases to be a
christian philosophy
like blondel and surya marcel discovers
christ giving not a new system
but a call to philosophy to continually
fundamentally reorient itself
determinately widening reason's range
philosophical reflection on the
incarnations quotes implications and
consequences of every order
generates the needed critical
perspective on reasons superficial
demands from the very start wrongly
posing themselves as inviolable
genuine philosophy reflective and
possessed of a metaphysical range
critiques these demands in the name of
higher demands and consequently in the
name of a superior reason that faith in
the incarnation puts precisely in the
condition of becoming fully conscious of
itself
clearly themes fundamental to marcel's
own philosophy are put into play when he
articulates this as quote metaphysical
elucidation of reason itself or of the
rational content that causes its
radically mysterious character to
re-emerge
while the incarnation remains christian
philosophy center marcel emphasizes that
quote the central light residing in the
incarnation radiates in reality through
all the regions of metaphysics
in his philosophical reflection on this
classic patristic insight marcel
identifies jillson's treatments of
themes developed in christian philosophy
as investigation of these quote multiple
or even indefinite radiations and
unfolds several of creation's
contributions to philosophy
nature is a created nature and this and
this precludes attributing to it that
sort of implicit and otherwise it's
unintelligible ipseity that naturalism
invests it with an expression of a
rationality understood in its poorest
and most formal sense
several connected implications of the
doctrine of creation for the christian
philosopher are that our reason is a
created reason ordered to created nature
and that it must by deepening itself
recognize what in it exceeds the domain
of adequacy to itself
thus
christian philosophy for marcel
is not a philosophical system but a
continually renewed way of doing
philosophy and provides human reason
more adequate conceptions of nature
reason itself and human being in
relation to the creative providentially
ordering and incarnate god
next section
neo-scholastic thomas opponents of
christian philosophy
although a number of neo-scholastic
signaled their opposition to the various
conceptions of christian philosophy
advanced during the debates the
positions of three philosophers of the
leuven school pierre mandonet ferdinand
von steinbergen and leon noel
supplemented by that of merlot penido
provide a suitably diverse
representation of the neo-scholastic
side
pierre mondonet
in the 1933 society thomeste session
mondonet adopts an extreme position
setting out a historical interpretation
reminiscent of brahirs quote
certainly christianity has transformed
the world but it has not transformed
philosophy
certainly christianity has been a
considerable factor of progress in
humanity but not progress of a
philosophical order
progress in the philosophical order does
not take place by scripture but by
reason
progress and philosophy therefore does
not take place by the paths of religion
even if there had been neither
revelation nor incarnation there would
have been development of science and
thought
well granting that one might speak of
christian philosophy as a christian
philosophical product that is the
product of the philosophical activity of
philosophers who happen to be christian
he adds but this will be a purely
personal matter they have their reasons
when they philosophies they have their
reasons for being christian the unity is
in the subject who finds himself being a
believer and a philosopher
it is not in the work they produce
their product he adds is in fact
theology not philosophy consequently
there is no christian philosophy and if
you leave even the word reason behind
you enter the domain of faith and you
can no longer be understood except among
believers
next subsection fernan von steinbergen
in marked contrast to mondonet who seems
unable to deal in anything but rigid
dichotomies or to consider his
opponent's positions von schneinbergen
commits to critical dialogue with his
interlocutors enabling him to set out a
stronger and more encompassing position
during the society tomi session noting
the expression christian philosophy has
no formal meaning he suggests its
replacement with another proposing
christian wisdom
then raises problems with three position
against maritime he grants that when
philosophy is integrated in a synthesis
with christianity it acquires a higher
value which is much more concrete but it
thereby becomes something quote of an
entirely different order
against marcel and sertian he cautions
is it conceivable when the christian
considers objects of revelation as such
that he can consider them otherwise than
as principles that should dominate his
synthesis
he targets a blundellian sense a
philosophy seeking christianity which
takes account of its own insufficiencies
pointing out there's nothing
determinately christian in taking stock
of one's own lacks revisiting the
society tomi session in his article van
steinbergen confesses that himself
confused that many of the participants
continued use of the term christian
philosophy discerning a tendency to give
to the expression in question a true
technical signification and to make of
christian philosophy a genre of
speculation intermediary between
philosophy to core and theology this
risks simply confusing philosophy and
theology to the detriment of both
he argues
that philosophy as a strictly rational
activity aims at a general explanation
of the real and christian thinkers ought
just as much as others aim at developing
philosophy fully
christianity however never intervenes
except in an indirect and accidental
manner in the development of philosophy
in this sense
any direct influence consists solely in
putting the philosopher in the best
condition to develop a true philosophy
he clarifies quote to the degree that it
is true a philosophy is necessarily
compatible with christianity open to
christianity utilizable by christianity
and by theology its content will be able
to partially coincide with that of
revelation
in contrast whenever revelation
intervenes as a source of knowledge
whether one starts from revelation to
explain it in reason or whether one
starts with reason in order to
illuminate it by revelation one is
always doing theology
von schainbergen accuses the
philosophical proponents of christian
philosophy of ambiguity of confusing
philosophy and theology he singles out
thomist interlocutors for also having
conflated quote the personal attitude of
the christian philosopher and the method
of philosophy the psychological coming
to be a being of a science and it's
logical coming to being
he also rejects historical appeals to
the existence of christian philosophies
since the very validity of the term
remains in question and he discerns a
need to react against a philosophy
already only to christian in the sense
that it integrates elements borrowed
from revelation or from theology without
assimilating them according to the
demands of its rational methods in the
interest of promoting a pure and true
philosophy
von steinberg's position is not simply
negative in place of a christian
philosophy between
philosophy and theology he suggests two
other activities one philosophical and
one theological agreeing with blondel
and certions that philosophy's task is
to extend itself so far as it can to all
reality
he proposes that in place of christian
philosophy philosophy of religion as
interpretation of religious phenomena
should include a sub-discipline
philosophy of christianity which would
study quote christianity as a historical
fact and as a social reality but it
would primarily be of use to apologetics
to which von steinbergen reduces
blondel's philosophy rather than a vital
interest
again addressing blondel
von steinbergen argues that every
sincere and complete philosophy is not
only a christian or catholic philosophy
not only a christian or catholic
philosophy must eventually culminate in
a philosophy of insufficiency which then
permits a philosophy of christianity in
addition to this philosophical
suggestion von steinbergen also proposes
a theology in the broad sense of
superior theology distinguished from
theology in the strict sense this would
be a quote totalization or a synthesis
of all the human knowledges a supreme
unification of all human knowing in
which the dominant element and the
principle of order will necessarily be
the revealed datum
in this theology would find its fruition
and unity in an ultimate effort of
integration of all human knowledge
next subsection
morillo or leo rather t l penito
after expressing concerns about the
autonomy of philosophy doing during the
society
thomas session in a subsequent article
penito raises three questions left at
the margins the exact meaning of the
historical problem the progress of
rationality and the constitution of
christian
christian philosophy and theology's role
in the constitution of christian
philosophy
penito suggests that the historical
problem as opposed to the doctrinal
instead of interrogating philosophers on
what they think and the abstract about
the relation between reason and faith
confine itself to discerning in their
works what their works owe to
christianity's influence addressing the
second problem he argues by exegesis
that thomas aquinas possesses a theory
of the progress of rationality
applicable within the historical study
of christian philosophy's development
lending itself to making sense of
certain differences separating greek
philosophy from christian philosophy
turning to the third he asks whether the
undisputable change of orientation noted
by historians was not actually
effectuated by christian theologians
rather than christian philosophers
suggesting it was the former who
meditated on the revelation and
effectuated the rectifications and
enlargements noted
the key question then becomes whether
the great thinkers of christian
antiquity in the middle ages none of
whom were solely philosophers when they
treated problems common to philosophy
and theology did this under the
illumination of christian philosophy
rather than that of theology
he argues it was the latter so that
christianity's observable influence on
philosophy remains simply extrinsic
leo noel last subsection
at the beginning of his contribution
noel distinguishes between two points of
view from the viewpoint of the
systematic philosopher in exposition of
the quote objective pattern of
connections of ideas of propositions of
reasonings a philosophy must be entirely
rational free from faith so it rests
only on evidence and remains purely
philosophical communicable to any other
mind even if it be an unbelieving one
and able to be discussed on the common
ground of certainties which all grant
from the historical viewpoint of the
genesis of a philosophical system or in
husserlian terms through the pattern of
connection of the acts by which the
subject comes to be occupied with these
objects
christianity can orient or aid the
process of study or the development of a
philosophical position or doctrine it
does so in and for the individual
philosopher
accordingly christian doctrines do not
enter as such into the objective
exposition of a philosophy or then that
philosophy would cease to be a
philosophy they cannot serve as such for
the basis of a reasoning but their
presence in the mind of the believer
can orient the research with a new
meaning
in this limited sense noel grants we can
speak of a christian philosophy meaning
by this
a philosophy
whose historical development took place
through the influence of christianity
but this is a less than rigorous way of
speaking and thinking he adds the
caution that the christian philosopher
who has been aided by christianity in
his or her philosophical research must
then strive to remove any dependence on
christian faith or doctrine in his or
her philosophical system so that it is
purely rational
accessible to the non-believer as it is
to his religious counterpart a
transcendent aspect will remain in
christian faith life and experience an
adequate study of this will admittedly
require subordinating one's judgment to
faith but this effort will then traverse
the boundary from philosophy into
theology
all the philosopher can do as a
philosopher is note this aspect's
irreducibility to rational explanation
keeping open
not for philosophy but for the
philosopher the doors through which
faith can pass where
the domain of theology begins
so that takes us up to page 85. we have
one more
session
coming up next thursday in which we'll
be reading thomas proponents of
christian philosophy who include antonin
certif
uh amy farrett
a.r mott
and
uh bruno de salaage
and then we're going to talk about uh
non-thomas proponents of christian
philosophy etienne born
michelle suriyo and henri gouier
um
as well
and that will take us to page 96 the
very end of the historical introduction
and then we jump into the first
translation emile brelies is there a
christian philosophy published in the
reviewed metaphysical morale in 1931.
so we're getting close to done with the
introduction
anybody's got questions or comments on
this i'm happy to
take them otherwise this might be a
little bit of a shorter
session
i'm still mulling over what i want to do
later on down the line after these
readings are done
maybe
some videos about this maybe
an online course maybe
something like a seminar
but you know as i go back through this
i'm
you know this is something i devoted
about
what about so nine
2003
to 2011. eight years of my life too
and continue to do some some digging
into these these figures i will mention
that of the people that i uh talked
about today
um
gabriel marcel's
uh
contributions are are in this book as
you know translated regarding the spirit
of medieval philosophy by mr etienne
gilson
the
van von steinbergen piece is also in
here as is the leon noel
the penito and
mondonet parts are not translated there
in the associated tom east second day of
studies
and of the
other people who i've mentioned
atn born and saved yanji and solage each
have
bits of things translated in this book
as well
so
uh uta
mishra are there any books for
pre-socratic philosophy that has nothing
to do with this uh yes you can google it
and find whatever you want right so
uh mark says how's everybody doing uh
i'm doing pretty good i didn't get all
the filming i wanted done this morning
but i'm hopefully gonna
do some of that after
um this is done and i have a little
lunch it's noon time here
so
any other
questions comments about the
readings from the book the topics
figures ideas
things like that
give it a minute
well i recharge on some of our great
local stone creek coffee
um oh so here's a good question this is
be trying to imagine how generalizable
this debate is to other religions
comparison to other religious
philosophical traditions so that's a
good question and there's a couple
things to be said one is you can't
imagine it you actually have to like
read the
the key documents of the debate and then
you have to know enough about the other
religious traditions that you would want
to
try to extend this to and then then you
could do that work but it's you can't
just generalize from this to say what
does this mean for buddhism or
confucianism
so the other thing to say is that
there are similar
discussions
that happen as secularization is taking
place like what what role
should
whatever understanding of hindu
philosophy and hinduism is a very
diverse batch of religious perspectives
how how could that um be understood you
know in terms of whether this really is
philosophy as they claim or or not we
could say similar things with
buddhism um we could say similar things
with confucianism and taoism we can say
similar things with
you know near eastern religions such as
zoastrianism judaism islam
baha'i
you know
we could talk about sikhism there's you
know really the stuff that we cover in
world religions if we understand those
traditions well enough
and we look at where discussions are
happening in terms of secularization
similar
issues would arise obviously
somebody like marcel insisting on the
incarnation okay that's not going to be
quite so important say
in
islam right
and it would have a very different
function say in mahayana buddhism or the
bodhisattva is important right so
all right uh mark
what would you say are the requirements
for somebody or something to classify as
christian are there some bare minimum
necessary tenants or practices
i mean
that's that's a tough one to say
augustine says that there are old women
who you know don't know anything about
theology and are illiterate and actually
know far more about
faith hope and charity
uh central christian virtues then do
many learning theologians right because
they're walking the walk rather than
just talking the talk
you know traditionally the nicene creed
these these creedal statements have been
important but anybody can mumble a creed
and not know what it actually means
um
so i i don't think that there is a
minimum thing unless you
index it to a particular community and
that's that's a difficult thing to do uh
particularly given that if you look at
the protestant spectrum we have over ten
thousand different denominations
and um
you know within catholicism we have all
sorts of like subgroups there's many
different rights
you know
we just had a recent moto proprio that
all the right-wingers are worked up
about you're taking away our latin mass
you know because it's our our authentic
mass and my my attitude towards them is
you know if you want something that's
closer to ancient liturgy go to a
maronite mass right where things are in
syriac because your your latin mass is
uh you know kind of young in that
respect
um so it's it's really tough to say like
you know who who would actually
establish this
uh b follows up by thinking of buddhist
philosophy and the nagarjuna uh vasa
bandu tradition
um is there a similar debate i don't
think there's a similar debate in that
tradition although i'm not an expert on
that if you're enough of an expert on
that
then maybe after reading through these
documents and the other things like you
know um
uh jill's song spirit of medieval
philosophy and mara tens already
translated essay on christian philosophy
you could make that determination for
yourself um i'm not i'm not
an expert i don't read poly or sanskrit
or anything like that so i would i would
hesitate to take a stand i i read french
so i was able to
you know
survey the whole of these debates um
those are those are the things that are
kind of needed as scholarly apparatus to
really dig into these things
uh any other questions or comments
going back to mark's question though i
will say this and this is a little bit
facetious but
when people present themselves to me as
christians that is as followers of
christ
and
um want to make all sorts of you know
claims about what christian morality is
or isn't or what it includes
i usually ask them one question
i say
how are you doing with living out the
sermon on the mount because if you're
not doing that i don't want to hear all
your other [ __ ] you know if you're
going to tell me about you know gay
rights and a man shall not lie with
another man as a woman from leviticus
and you can't find anything else in the
bible you know about that i'm going to
say how are you doing with uh not having
any anger towards your brother or
calling them raqqa or any of that sort
of stuff how are you doing with them
adultery how are you doing with
helping the poor because that's the
stuff that seems to have gotten a lot
more play in the
christian and in the
previous jewish scriptures
right
um particularly the prophets so
that's that's for me an index of of uh
whether one really is committed to this
this figure of christ following the
actual teachings
you know they're hard
to put into play
right um
it's a lot easier to be like you know
pro-life
meaning just protest about abortion
and vote republican but not actually
do the things that would be across the
board you know they talk about the
seamless garment of life right womb to
tomb
those are those are the real measures i
think
anybody can profess a belief living it
out that's much much more difficult
um any other questions
comments ideas
ah
mark says
any notable discussion of the sermon on
the mount in these debates um
not as such not thematically
um
but you know all these the the catholic
interlocutors are all people who are
basically living it out um you know
blondel is a great example marcel is a
great example um
of that sort of thing
made of clay could you do the belief yet
not claim the identity
yeah i mean any you can do whatever you
want it's a free country right
in in places where
christians are persecuted
you might actually want to
have the belief but not make a big
public declaration of it unless you want
to be a martyr right
um and you could say the same thing
about about muslims who have to conceal
their muslim identity or
um you know buddhists who have to
conceal their buddhist identity
sure uh that's not the norm that's
that's outlier stuff but yeah
all right any other questions or or
comments
well let me tell you as we're winding
down then so next thursday
we finish out the introduction that's
going to be kind of nice because then we
can move into the actual translations
that motivated me writing this book in
the first place
we spent now what two months
two two and a half months talking about
the introduction um maybe i shouldn't
have written such a long introduction
and
that'll be fun and i'll i'll be thinking
about what i want to do with this
down the line you know
maybe i'll make some resources or things
like that i used to give talks about
this quite frequently back when the book
first came out but then you know you've
only got so much time and i was doing a
lot of stuff on on other thinkers and on
anger and on
aristotle and stoicism and anselm and
people like that so
all right well thanks everybody for
joining me for this this reading and i
will see you next thursday for the next
one and we'll finish out the
introduction